the beach ball strategy is a way to get
students who might not want to answer
questions or be a little less outgoing
in their answering of questions to
answer questions so there's a few
different ways to use the beach ball
actually and and one is you just posed a
question that has enough variation in
the types of responses so you wouldn't
say okay what's 2+2 as an as an example
for the beach ball question you would
have to have something that was a little
bit more a little bit richer and then
you throw the ball at at one student or
up into the up into the lecture hall if
it's a big lecture hall and whoever
catches it has to respond and that
response you share it with the group
comment on it if you want to comment on
it and then that person who gave the
first response throws the ball to
somebody else and then whoever catches
the ball that time responds etc you can
use it coupled with a picture prompt or
or a graph so if you show a graph or an
image and you say tell me one thing
tell me something you observe about this
image and then you throw the ball and
the person that catches it first says
one thing they observe and they throw it
and the next person says something that
they observed about the picture prompt
so that that that gives a foundation and
it opens up space for lots of responses
it doesn't the beach ball does a few
things one is that as the instructor you
don't have to be the one that calls on
on the students all the time so the
students don't feel like you're picking
on them that you're the one that's cold
calling on them and in fact you can
throw the beach ball completely blind
the first time close your eyes throw the
ball and and so nobody really feels that
you've called on them and then
subsequently it's other students that
are throwing the ball so there's no
issue about about you that you're the
one that's picking on the students the
other thing is it's kind of fun you're
throwing the ball around so it it's hard
to get upset it's hard to get as a
student or nervous that you're gonna
you're gonna have to answer the question
and in fact you could dodge the ball if
you really didn't want to answer the
question so it's a great way to get
students talking and in general it's
it's pretty fun and
at first I thought oh I can't really use
this with grad students it's it's too
goofy it's too it's too baby or silly
but but actually every time I use it
with grad students postdocs everybody
seems perfectly fine with it I think
it's more to do with the nature of the
question if you just ask stupid
questions and throw the ball around
it'll be stupid but if you ask good
questions and it's a way for students to
get to give you their answers then it
seems to work totally fine that's the
general way sometimes I'll actually
write questions on the beach ball and
then throw the ball into the into the
class and then students are loosely
supposed to answer the question that's
in front of them when they catch the
ball so that's another way to do it but
it's a nice inexpensive fairly flexible
technique